[Musique]
on fait pas une politique de droite
lorsqu'on ne baissent pas les dépenses
publiques et qu'on les augmente plus
vite de manière plus importante que les
augmenter françois hollande on ne fait
pas une politique de droite lorsqu'on
augmente de 30% la csg on ne fait pas
une politique de droite lorsqu'on met
l'école dans la situation où elle est
aujourd'hui
mais une fois que l'on a dit ça ça ne
suffit pas on ne rebondira pas
uniquement dans l' attaque contre
emmanuel macron l'attaquent contre le
pen
on rebondira par la capacité d'être
lisible sur nos propositions on doit
parler à tous les français
moi je ne me résous pas à ce que avec
parfois un peu du marketing électoral
qui est grosso modo le parti des gens
qui vont bien qu'ils réussissent le
parti macro nist et à une espèce de
blocs protestataires de gens qui vont
pas bien
la france périphérique d'un côté la
france intégrés dans les métropoles
mondialisé de l'autre ça ça ne me va pas
moi je pense aux militants je pense à
ceux qui croient en nous je pense à des
gens comme moi qui croient en la droite
et au centre
eh bien je pense qu'on doit porter un
nouveau projet et renouer avec
l'espérance
il faut y croire d'abord et puis il ya
toujours le sport parce que la droite
française n'est pas mort et moi je
continue à avoir une espérance dans ce
parti parce que je pense que c'est le
parti de la cinquième république
c'est le parti qui au départ y glisse
c'est le parti démocrate chrétien c'est
le parti de la laïcité c'est le parti
qui est à mon avis un avenir entre deux
échecs qui est l'échec de monsieur
macron tôt ou tard et des impasses du
rassemblement national
notre parti les il est riche d'une
histoire il a un avenir à proposer aux
français
il a des positions singulières qui ne
sont pas des demi réformes pour les uns
et puis pour les autres des réformes qui
conduirait le pays à la ruine la
situation politique nous place face à un
défi démocratique
le pire ça serait de se renier mais je
ne suis pas du tout dans le reniement
j'ai pas non plus du tout dans leurs
aliments les républicains sont pas à
vendre au plus offrant on n'est pas là
pour être dépecer on n'est pas vendre on
n'est pas être acheté je trouve cela
tout à fait indécent espèce de
tentatives de démarchage qui viennent de
gauche de droite d'ailleurs
[Musique]